welcome again to the expert briefing
series uh i am conrad one of the
co-chairs
of this year's pi data global conference
we have marco here to talk to us about
nlp
all right thank you for the introduction
and thank you all for uh for joining the
session i hope you are
enjoying the this first couple of days
of pay data global and hopefully the the
conference
the main event coming up next week will
uh
will also be very nice
um
so the presentation will be roughly 15
minutes uh the title not range
processing
trends challenges and opportunities that
when we started talking about doing this
kind of sessions we were thinking in
terms of uh you know catching up with
the state of the art
but i like the idea of just talking
about where we're going with the field
and what people are struggling on
and
where we we can go essentially so more
broader and awfully relaxed discussion
so after the presentation
your input will be very much
appreciated any kind of question or
comment
i have a few talking points if uh
if nobody has any burning question i can
ask you some questions and maybe you'll
tell me
uh your views on
on natural language processing
um
that's a
picture of me in my better days
i work as a data science consultant
in the python and
python and data
space
and they do a lot of training and
coaching also in the python
space
pandas psychic learner and whatnot
apart from work um i
am an organizer of the pediatric chapter
uh together with uh with conrad
and i've been sharing the past couple of
uh
editions of our annual conference we
have an annual conference and a monthly
meetup everything of course now is uh
on hold uh hopefully we will have the
chance to resume uh everything soon
before
becoming a data science consultant i
spent some time in academia my
background is information retrieval
that's where my interest for uh natural
language processing is coming from i was
developing at the time
um semantics search engines before that
was a software engineers for a few years
and that's uh
20 years
summarized in a
in a sentence now enough about me
let's talk about natural language
precisely now
now my um
assumption here is that you simply have
some interest in natural language
processing if you're here
we don't assume anything in terms of
expertise some of you
are learning some of you maybe are using
nfp already
some of you are simply curious to see
what is going on
with with nlp and why
why is nfp
interesting why is it important well
when you break it down there are sort of
two sides of the story the uh what you
call natural language understanding or
nlu and natural language generation or
energy but besides the
all the acronyms that you might find
essentially what we are trying to do is
uh
we want to understand the language and
we want to produce language
kind of like
we do as as humans
so that's the overall idea with the
with nlp and the applications are
countless so you can see
already why this is an interesting
field
such a challenging field
let me give you just one example if you
get this sentence how do you extrapolate
any meaning out of this that that's
proper english i'm not uh i'm not joking
that's proper english that that is is
that that and i'll just give up
um i guess it's kind of difficult to to
pass now the the trick here is that i i
left out the the punctuation once you
put it in is actually a reference to
some of the um
all the philosophers from back in the
days and you can find a lot of this kind
of linguistic
examples linguistic
situations where
it's kind of difficult to parse
um going beyond this simple example of
you know why is this challenging
let me give you an example about
ambiguity they ate a pizza with
anchovies and you can see from the
picture there are two possible
interpretations here this one in
particular is what we call a syntactic
ambiguity
essentially you can read the sentence in
two different ways
and
maybe a person would have some kind of a
common sense and understand the context
but from a
from a computer perspective from a you
know an algorithmic perspective this is
still a
relatively
difficult
challenge to to sort out at large
we also have ambiguities
at the word level so the same word maybe
can have multiple interpretations and
again a context could be
um
could be relevant here to understand so
the summary is that language is
challenging why is it challenging we
we saw a couple of examples but
something to consider is that first of
all language is evolving
and often in nlp we we use maybe data
sets that are in the public domain but
they were
produced they were curated
20 30 years ago are they still
relevant well that's to be something to
consider
language is ambiguous as we seen in a
couple of examples earlier we have
ambiguity at the word level at the
syntactic level
and context is what we need so to
understand language we need context we
need
some kind of common sense
applied as well
so
not very short language is challenging
and
in order to cut tackle
challenging language problems typically
we need the data to support our
algorithms and more precisely we need
annotated
data now the problem with annotated data
we can find annotated data uh
but there is a lot going on in in the
space that goes beyond the
what is our specific domain and so
variability of of the language is also
to consider often we
maybe we use a data set of uh
i don't know newswire articles from 20
years ago as i mentioned
is our business domain news newswire
articles is there anything that happened
in the past 20 years that maybe is not
reflected in the language
are we using a language that is not
english
so
all these variables are to be considered
so for this reason i say available data
uh at least kind of in the public domain
tends to be sparse sparse as in
there's a lot of data but data that is a
high quality and good for our specific
domain for our specific task for our
specific language
is a bit more sparse
so that's one of the one of the issues
and also more recently probably in the
past five years or so we've been
discovering uh more and more about
bias in the data
we often treat uh
annotated data as
you know
the golden truth or the ground truth
but somebody did the annotation so
naturally we will have a bias in the in
the data itself
and as i said
we've been talking a bit more in the
past five years or so in parallel with
the
sort of the whole field of data science
growing up and realizing that there is a
whole branch of
ethical implications in what we do
and ngp
is also following the same pattern with
workshops dedicated to the topic
annotated data is also
i call it a bottleneck essentially still
expensive still takes a lot of time
and and effort to do so even though
for uh
you know if you need to come up with a
an idea for a side project you will find
something easily in the public domain
once you need to sort solve a specific
problem in a specific domain in a
specific language
things are not always so
easy to to to get
i've been talking about a couple of
challenges here
let's talk about uh how the field has
evolved in uh
in a minute or so so i will give you a
very incomplete
history of nlp in three bullet points
tribulati points because we essentially
talk about three different
families of approaches
first of all in parallel with
the
first efforts in the ai space at large
we can talk about the symbolic nlp or
rule-based nfp a lot of work that goes
kind of long before the 50s but i put
the 1950s as a starting point because
that's when a lot of workers
started to happen
at the time
linguistics as a field was also kind of
a bit more involved
a lot of ideas were developed from
linguistics and the people were trying
to bring them towards the
algorithmic side
fast forward a few decades later in the
90s we have seen the the rise of uh
you know different machine learning
approaches and a more
statistical approach to us nfps west so
the use of
annotated data in nlp and extracting
statistics from annotated data and
we can disagree on the exact days here
roughly
at some point in the 90s that's where
things started to to pick up and
we stayed there for a little while until
the uh
the past decades let's say from 2010 or
so
when we've seen the rise of
a lot of deep learning approaches in a
lot of different fields
nfpk maybe a little bit later compared
to two other fields
but these days
a lot of what is happening in terms of
the latest uh
r d is also happening in the deep
learning uh space
so
just three bullet points to give you the
history because essentially here we have
the summary of uh
what kind of models are used in nlp and
as we as we see this kind of evolution
from rule based to
statistical and machine learning type of
models to deep learning type of models
essentially we can look at how
we have been evolving in terms of data
representation and the the application
of specific algorithms from the data
representation point of view for many
many years we've been doing a bag of
words
um there are references of the
uh phrase bag of words
already in in the 50s
and it's been used
quite a while the whole feature
engineering story uh with the more
traditional machine learning approaches
more recently uh i put the 2013
again we can disagree on the on the
dates but i put 2013 as a reference to
the world to vac
paper that triggered a lot of further
research has been a move towards
a representation based on word
embeddings that's not when word
embeddings have been invented we had
references to uh some of the ideas also
in in the previous decades but that's
probably when
kind of everybody started talking about
uh word embeddings or you know in the in
the following couple of years 2014 2015
both from a research point of view and
also from a more practical point of view
with the
libraries supporting
world medics in a way that is uh
relatively easy to use
so with word embeddings we've been
moving from using
from representing data with a bag of
words to our to us representing data as
vectors that capture uh
semantics similarity between concepts
and the whole story of compositionality
so maybe if you have
seen a previous presentation on where to
deck you're familiar with the
king minus men plus woman equal queen
type of example
so that's for the data representation on
the algorithmic side well it depends on
on the task but let's say we've been
shifting from
let me call them traditional machine
learning models whatever traditional
means i'm not a big fan of the
terminology so i put it in double quotes
but you you will find often this as a
reference
so old school
machine learning models and then
around 2015 each
we
have seen
a lot of examples of recurring neural
networks and long short-term memory uh
nato's been applied again we can
disagree on the exact data here i'm just
referencing some of the
products from
google i don't remember this google
translate or other that were pushed a
lot around
that data
lstm per se goes back to the mid 90s
as as a proposal at least
but nobody was really using it
for nfp at large so it became very very
popular around those those days
and from there a couple of years later
we have seen the rise of the uh
transformers
family of the transformer family of
models separate 2017 as a reference to
the attention is all you need the
paper and then probably 2018 2019 is
really when everything took off
and these days in terms of
research at least the the state of the
art seems to be moving towards a
different flavor of transformers
architecture then the question for me is
whether
you know everybody is everybody using it
or is everybody talking about
those type of
models so that's the the summary of the
evolution of the models and uh
since i should be touched on the state
of the art i should also mention the
dedicated slide to the transformers
architecture so um
it's kind of difficult to summarize in a
slide so i just give you a couple of
points over why
transformers uh
became so popular so a couple of things
that they brought
to the table is first of all the
option for parallelization so data
didn't need to be
processed sequentially anymore
so opening the door for parallelization
means we have seen
the
opportunity to train on bigger and
bigger data sets so kind of cutting the
the training time or potentially having
the same training time but on a much
bigger data set
in parallel to this
idea of parallelization we have seen
also the
opportunity to fine tune on a specific
task so often this kind of architectures
they are
pre-trained on a
generic data set could be wikipedia or
it could be
something general purpose and then they
have the option of fine-tuning for the
specific task for your specific domain
with a smaller
set of
annotated data
so this is the the main two points that
uh i guess as a family
of architectures the transformers have
brought to the table
so as a tendency that we have seen as as
a result of
having transformers available now we see
bigger and bigger models being pushed so
when you look at the
leaderboard the type of
tables on the on the state of the art
for different tasks at least when you
try to catch up with the academic
literature you will find bigger and
bigger models being released
and also
more and more a pre-trained model has
been released so a lot of the big names
google and facebook and whatnot they
released their uh
models as a pre-trained and open source
uh
in a way the pre-trained model that you
can download and reuse locally we've
seen this uh
with uh with world tobacco from 2013 and
at the time i guess it was not so common
to
release a pre-trained model in a kind of
binary format that you just downloaded
and you can reuse
but in recent years we have seen
a lot more of this
now i mentioned 2017 as a starting point
of
you know when the transformers uh
started to take off with the with the
reference to the attention is all you
need the paper and i want to point out
the paper trigger a lot of additional
work so there's 29 000
citations
as at least this afternoon
so 29 000 other papers that cite the
attention is all you need one meaning a
lot of work has been happening in uh in
the field and uh to be honest i haven't
read
29 000 papers so when we when we spoke
about that you know let's talk about the
state of the art in in different fields
it's kind of difficult to catch up with
these days because there are so many new
uh pieces of research coming out in the
field that is really really difficult to
to stay up to date
earlier this year i came across
this nice diagram that's the link at the
bottom
uh from a research group of a university
in beijing
where they try to map
some of these
architectures thus
birth and
gpt that you might have
heard of if you keep an eye on what's
going on with that with nlp and then
many many more and there's just a tiny
uh
picture you know taken from those 29 000
uh citations
there's quite a few different models
going on here as you can see
so the the space
uh is becoming a
very crowded and it's evolving very
rapidly so it's very difficult to to
catch up
there's also another direction that
people are starting to consider um
earlier this year there was an
interesting paper a kind of a positional
paper if you want
the challenge is this idea and
they call this type of pre-trained
models or sort of large-scale language
models that we've seen these days
stochastic pirates there's been a bit of
a misunderstanding of what these big
language models are
some people talk about them as if
artificial general intelligence is a
problem that we have now sold
uh some people to
reference this as a parrot so they can
simply repeat
what they see in the data and they do so
in a way that is often quite quite
interesting useful and surprising
uh but that's what they are they're
language models so they give you a
probability of a string
based on the training data and then it
can be as sophisticated as we want
but that's what they are
and the question they ask in this paper
is uh are these models too big so is
this really the best direction uh for uh
for the field and uh they list quite a
few uh points
for example the financial cost of this
type of models also the environmental
impact of training
this huge model and doing research in in
this direction
and a few other points that is worth uh
considering so um
nice uh a nice reference to uh
to uh to check out as well
before closing the the presentation and
um opening the floor for a discussion um
i also want to mention the python nfp
ecosystem so back in the days
there was only an ltk which is roughly
20 years old and then
over time luckily other tools came up
and
they're doing well they're easy to use
they're nice they offer a nice interface
they offer a lot of support for a lot of
existing algorithms i want to mention
psychic learn because even though it's a
general purpose machine learning library
they do have some components that are
useful for uh nlp
uh jane simmer became very very popular
when they implemented the worldvac
version in python and
at the time it was actually faster than
the original
c implementation
from from google so they made a lot of
noise around i guess 2014 or so uh
spacey was uh
uh born also a few years ago uh general
purpose library they offer a lot of
a lot of options for a lot of different
tasks and then something a bit more
specialized rasa if you're developing
conversational agents
raza seems to be one of the go-to uh
tools these days and finally again phase
as a
hub
for the transformers uh
library they they have a transformers
library they have a data set library and
they work as a
as a company they are essentially a hub
where they uh offer
access to this kind of pre-trainer uh
models and uh they have a lot going on
on the on the nlp side
there's probably
many more libraries to to mention here
but these are sort of the big names so
that you will uh that you will find in
the in the field
okay that was a uh quick uh
intro uh that's essentially the end of
the um the presentation now uh we're
gonna open the the floor for a bit of a
discussion
just want to mention on my
website myfullname.com
you'll have references to the
all my previous presentations about nlp
and all other topics i also run a
newsletter about the python data and
then the usual social media thing if you
are
so inclined
so that's uh that's all on my side let
me
stop the
screen share
and we can open the floor for uh
for the uh discussion so i'm happy to
get to take
questions you can either type it in the
chat or sort of raise your hand and ask
away
um i'm going to
paste also some
links in the in the chat i have the
slides for the presentation i have my
my contacts and i have a reference to my
upcoming trainings as well in uh in
december on pandas and
nlp
so you will get the
all the links in one place
um i have some talking points if nobody
asked a question
okay something popping up uh
okay is it asking
get started with nlp maybe perhaps a
simple classifier out of all the options
it's a good place to get started imagine
they want the first useful solution
before
before worrying about the state of the
art yeah
the
first useful uh
solution
one of my talking points actually is
when we implement
natural language processing solutions
is it really different from
any kind of data science problem
or is it just a
kind of a specific area of data science
but we we should sort of follow
the
the wisdom that hopefully we we have
from uh designing data science solutions
and deploying data science solutions
uh so the good starting point is to have
the
simplest possible
baseline that works end to
and then
iterate and improve from there and in
terms of a simple baseline for um
for nlp
i guess what we call earlier traditional
machine learning approaches support
vector machines
often seen for for many many years as a
state-of-the-art in in-text
classification
if you want a classifier to start with
or really any
classifier would make a good baseline in
that case you still need to consider
the
feature engineering aspect so for future
engineering
what we know from traditional uh
nap courses and uh information retrieval
courses about uh
um
back awards about uh tfidf those kind of
uh
concepts that have been around for a
while
that's what i would consider a
solid baseline a good starting point and
you have the benefit of
explainability sort of easy to
understand easy to debug
before moving towards a more complex
system or systems or solutions
all right let me let me catch up with
the chat the
seti says
thank you for sharing thank you for
attending
can you share your view about nlp on
non-english foreign languages
yes the
amount of data
for language in general is growing
rapidly and the amount of data for
non-english
language is growing very very rapidly
let me say today is better than five
years ago in terms of availability of
data we have at the very least we have
people asking this question
which is a good starting point
oftentimes we kind of default to english
also in research
we default to english
as
the main english the domain language but
um
there's a lot going on in terms of
data being available and annotated data
in particular
for for foreign languages um
i don't have
probably a uh you know if you ask me for
this particular language what do i do i
i don't have a an answer for uh for
everything uh but good places to to
check out are typically wikipedia that
is often available in uh
so the same articles are available in
several languages
um
for european languages the the
transcripts of the european parliament
there's a little bit more also for
french from the canadian parliament they
do
side by side english to french
like the european parliament they do
side by side
english to french to german to all the
other official languages
yeah
at least there is some
some awareness
of the fact that there are more
languages than english and the people
want to do nfp on more language so we
start seeing
more
resources available
what books would you matteo is asking
what books would you
suggest as good general references for
nlp uh this many
[Music]
many books to be honest uh
that we could think of let me uh
just see if they are actually uh
available for free uh there's something
on the academic side if you are
interested on the algorithmic
uh aspect of it more on the
theory side
and
for nlp
there's foundations
of natural language processing by mining
and shoots
so i think it's uh you can read it
online i don't know if this was a pdf
so let me let me put the link in the
chat
foundations of
can it be
statistical
nlp
so link in the chat for the uh
foundation of statistical p book it's uh
probably 20 years old
so um
it focuses on statistical llp
doesn't necessarily have the the latest
state of the art but a lot of ideas here
are really
useful and still applicable these days
if you want
something more
more recent and more on the deep
learning side i found that the uh i
don't have it here the deep learning
with python by
francois chalet um who's the author of
keras
to have some good material also on on
nlp so
deep learning
with python
by
francois
is published by manning so i don't think
you will find it uh
free online unless you have a like
safari or one of those subscriptions
i can mention another 20 but probably
two is a good starting point and ltk you
also have the
ltk book
good for learning sort of general
introduction but it's a little bit less
modern i would say
these days people tend to use maybe
spacey a bit more in the twisted
industry
as a go-to
library
but they do have the book for free so
you might check that one
as well nltknltk.org
then i don't know if it's slash sorry
nltntk.org
well
i don't know why it goes on a new line
on my screen
uh okay i hope i gave you the answer uh
let me catch up
oh that's a question
what do you use to uh for the
interpretation of
transformers that's uh
that's the challenging one that's
ongoing uh research so one of the
um
one of the criticism
for people
who are not into deep learning research
in general is the
uh
the fact that often it feels like these
models are simply black box models and
we don't know what's going on
on the inside
i think we we're not there yet uh so
interpretability
of uh transformers at large is still an
ongoing area of research so
oftentimes
we we kind of have to experiment with uh
with our own data so you pull a
pre-trained model and you see how it
behaves
with
some kind of cherry picked examples on
on your data i don't have a specific
experience on uh
doing something a bit more formal uh
like like you could do with uh
uh more traditional models here yeah
it's uh it's an open uh question at
least for me and if anybody has a
experience on in this direction and
you're also welcome to contribute
okay let me
let me then ask you a question for those
of you who
[Music]
use nlp who are nfp practitioners uh
what do you use it for
and uh what is it that you find more
challenges so what are your biggest sort
of pain points when you try to implement
an nlp solution and then you can tell us
if you are
more of a specialist or a data scientist
who doesn't have an nlp background based
to work on nlp problems maybe
um
so what uh what do people work on if you
do work on nlp you have any example of a
project that you would like to mention
anything that was challenging
so so i i think i think for me from from
like the perspective of uh not a
professional like uh nlp person at all
right uh
the the challenging part is to
i i think especially for some of the
earlier models uh you know like the
word event or like uh like stuff that
like it's easier to wrap your head
around
um like like that stuff is okay fine
like it's like easy to do i i can try to
like work through this myself and do it
but then you so you get from like zero
to like maybe 90 percent of the thing
working
uh but but to get from like 90 to like
95 or 99 and like a
you know fine-tuning that extra model
it's just
like like suddenly like the
you go from like oh this is like
manageable to like oh i have i'm way out
of my depth and i have no clue what's
happening for the you know as you said
the
uh transformed models and like like
that's
some of the more complicated stuff
um yeah except for yeah for for me as a
non are you talking about uh like
improving the quality of what you have
or are you talking about the
switching from a baseline to a more
state-of-the-art type of model yeah so
so improving uh what i have which is
basically either knowing how to tweak it
or like maybe you want to like use a
more state-of-the-art model both of
which are i i like i i feel like i do
not have any expertise in
yeah
yeah
that's why we we have data scientists
right
it's a it's an ongoing process typically
it's not
a
one-off thing just like
tackling any data science
problem here we simply have a language
type of data but
you want to
to have some kind of baseline early on
so you can
start doing some error analysis
looking at what goes wrong
something that people often
don't consider also is
did you talk to the business domain
experts
maybe they can tell you a bit more about
your data and why why you see what you
see and what are the expectations
um
so
as a data scientist we have the tendency
of jumping into you know sorting out the
problem with an algorithmic approach but
often
the the understanding of
the underlying business and why do we
have the data they look the way they
look
uh and all those kind of questions
uh they need to be asked essentially
um and then it's a matter of
trying to understand whether your uh you
mention 90 percent let's say if it's 90
quality
um
is that good enough and the the price to
go from
90 to 95
is a really worth paying that price so
often there is a lot of
effort going on for just a marginal
improvement a tiny improvement so
[Music]
i would say that's not
necessarily an nlp only problem it's a
broader data science type of problem
then talking about the switching from
the more traditional more baseline like
type of models to the more advanced ones
yeah
there's a lot of complexity going on and
it took me a while to
kind of understand what is going on with
the transformers architecture
my suggestion is if you really really
want to
fully understand what what is going on
there you
you need to look at the papers you need
to look at the research papers and
get your hands dirty with the sort of
linear algebra
or whatever it is is going on in in
different models and see what they bring
to the table
i am
i rarely have the need to be really on
top of the very latest
thing that is happening so i have the
luxury often over
uh sort of uh
i can wait a little bit
for all the all the buzz to come down
so more
accessible resources pop-up
blogs and uh
and youtube videos and whatnot that are
available so
um
yeah there's there's a few different
resources
in
[Music]
in simpler
formats simpler as in not using academic
language like a scientific paper that
are more
labor layperson type of
language
um
for example there's a like an
illustrated transformer a blog post that
was popular a couple of years ago
and then there was a
narrated transformer which was the the
youtube version of it so those kind of
things tend to pop up a couple of years
after the
the the main
research paper is presented so
[Music]
there are options if you start looking
into it but
bottom line if you really want to
understand
the
the details you need to look at the the
original research papers
at least i learned more about the
transformers architecture reading the
research paper then reading 20 blog
posts that were just repeating the same
kind of high level ideas
so that's at least my my experience so
far so you need to kind of get
comfortable with that that level math
um and if that's not something that
comes easily to you you you know bring
it to a local uh
data science
journal club or something we have uh you
know
those type of meetups where people uh
uh bring an academic reference and then
you discuss it together that's also an
option asking for help in those kind of
circles
um
we had the
lev running one in in london a couple of
years back
so that would be my suggestion
okay
uh
let's see on the chat my domains finance
main challenge is capturing domain
specific context yeah often the
financial corpus is too small or too
expensive and attacked by experts so
spend most of my time
on the
catering data gathering annotation
performance accuracy and general corpus
may not be the same as specific corpus
yes you are describing
a common issue we have a lot of this
general purpose english newswire
english data available out there
and there is a good chance that our
business domain is now newswire general
post english so
uh yeah that's what we said annotation
is still the bottleneck talking to the
experts
still something that you have to do
still expensive time consuming and
everything that we that we know already
and i don't think there's a magic
solution here simply we we kind of have
to do it
the
when some guy a few years ago said data
is the new oil uh sounded uh you know
a bit uh a bit fluffy maybe at the time
but that's uh that's what is happening
so your data your business domain your
expertise and the expertise of your ps
uh will be important for your domain so
i see the the pre-trained models on
wikipedia and whatnot just as a starting
point to start
playing with the tools to have a flavor
of the
the apis and whatnot
but then if you have
an actual problem to solve you will have
to
bring your data into the into the uh
discussion
right um
yeah any any other question or uh
talking point or uh
comment from
anybody uh
yeah i may try if you can hear me please
yeah
hi marco uh hi there
thank you for for your answer on the
question on uh for our talk uh first
your question on interpreting
transformers uh i've been working for
the past year on an lp
a recent
developer converted to data sense
an excellent choice
yes yeah absolutely not i didn't get
bored uh at all yeah i really love it
and uh yeah i find it was great to to
work on an ap because there's so many
it's so mature
maybe compared i want i think compare
for example to computer vision because
in lp you have those great libraries
like spacey or hugging face
uh or all the ones you mentioned like
any ketogenic scene that enables you to
build things so quickly
um
and yeah the question you wear what do
you use it for but to me it's basically
to build classifier but unless and
instead of using like
tabular data you use a
full text
and yeah for for interpretation i was
asking because i just starting to look
into this like looking at chap or lime
it's not really satisfying
is it like lime you
would be doing an isis only on a
single token level
ideally you would like to be able to you
have a classifier
and you have a piece of text and you
want to say okay this is this sentence
in the full text which contributed
highly into making that prediction
and yeah i'm trying to find if that's
that's doable but uh
yeah it's it's a hard one no it's it is
uh it is are the the the tools that you
mention and this um
several others
available there was a talk let me
let me look it up briefly
yeah there it is uh
i'm gonna put a youtube
link on the on the chat as well uh this
one was a talk given uh
at petite london at the meet up uh
by
dean
dean uh stop i think
um where he went through a lot of
different uh tools for um
explaining machine learning mode so it's
not specific for an np but it gives you
a nice overview on
on explainable machine learning um
yeah
the
the work on
on the deep learning side i would say
it's ongoing so all those dues they tend
to be more on the
more traditional sort of future
engineering uh side of things they can
be helpful for uh for that
um
so i agree can be
a little bit frustrating at times and
it's definitely not to solve the problem
the the youtube link is pointing to that
talk i also want to point out in case
you're new to pi data
all the pi data talks at least from the
past few years from different
conferences different meetups they end
up on the pi data youtube channel so
there's countless
hours of entertainment on youtube for
you if
if you are so inclined
thank you for sharing um
you mentioned classification um what's
the if you can tell us what's the the
use case what are you classifying is it
topic
of course yeah so i've done a bit of
topic modeling so to basically explore
your data
um
an iphone
and i mean and then i've done some
classification to classify and task so
i'm working i'm doing a bit i'm doing
research basically as a freelance for
um
a company who build a an ai product for
insurances
and basically their aim is to
automatically
classify claims
from uh people like uh uh have a
a hiring issue my tv got broken my cat
has been running around in in the living
room got crazy pushed the tv fell on the
floor and now it has cracks it doesn't
turn on anymore
and basically we want to understand yeah
who did that why is it broken what type
of damage it has
and
this is why we build like classifiers uh
we worked also on outer detection i mean
there is so many different things you
can do there
um
right
and
one question often i often ask um our np
is when do you now use
um
machine learning models
because
anytime i try deep learning models i
always get top performance i mean it's
clearly the state of the arts
and now even with like larger models or
which driveway i'm very interested to
video the paper you mentioned about like
the like the
the pirate issue but um
i mean
even now you can with natural language
inference with there are a few shots
learning you can create model
thanks to large pre-trained model you
can create models with
little amount of data
so in which circumstances do you
do you happen to use like to get back to
apart from doing a baseline do you end
with model in production but use for
example tf idf
and
yeah mexico question or something like
this yeah yeah yeah why not you know if
it works why not
my
as a rule of thumb and uh and we can
disagree on the the numbers here if i
have less than 5 000 documents
then you know what does it mean are we
talking about tweets or are we talking
about long wikipedia articles so
the the size of a data set is not just
that the number of documents but also
number of words and all the stuff but
if you want a number my starting point
would be less than 5 000 documents i
wouldn't even look at any
deep learning approach i i would expect
uh those approaches to simply pick up
noise maybe they work well
in in some setting but maybe they they
will not uh
work well on
[Music]
you know on the data that you get in the
wider so that that would be my personal
uh rule of thumb
uh if you don't have a lot of data
uh
don't bother essentially go with the
traditional uh
back
and traditional uh
um
logistic regressions and so on for word
embeddings it depends on the total
number of words i would say if you have
at least
100 000 words so the
count of the all the words you will
start seeing
some of the similarities between
concepts being captured by the
embeddings but just about if you have
more than one million words
um then definitely you will see the
similarities and and those uh
relationships you know king minus men
plus woman equal queen those kind of
things will pop up so i would say one
million words
is probably um
as a rule of thumb a good starting point
one million words is not a big data set
is a thousand documents with a thousand
words each roughly um
so word embeddings at least for uh
an exploratory data analysis uh exercise
i would check them out see if i
in fact with a client we did something
like that we had the simple logistic
regression classifier in production and
then we did the word to back
thing with a nice
dashboard to
visualize which
concepts were close to each other
it didn't end up in production but it
was very very useful to learn about the
data
so you you can still uh check it out you
know
as a prototype why not
yes it's also what i usually do as a
baseline to
breed something very very quickly
i i wonder what uh have you ever had to
to work on bias on reducing the bias you
can
you have a chance to do that uh
not directly
no i can i can point you to the sort of
usual
references that you will
see out there i don't have direct
experience on reducing
reducing bias for a specific project
okay
all right
let me catch up with the chat your
funniest interest in nlp application use
case uh okay i'll also uh place it in in
the chat there was a talk i gave at pi
data
um
two three four years ago
uh
okay
that's my best buddy at the moment and
i want to make clear it was a joke um
it was a just a side project done as a
joke
next
would you say there is any added value
for nlp research coming from domain
specific studies for example cognitive
linguistics so are there any
inspirations in nfp drone from theories
about how do brain community process
language meaning metaphors
um
one of my
one of the points that i wrote down as a
talking point in case nobody
and the question was
do we still need linguistics is
linguistic still still relevant and
the feeling is that yeah now with deep
learning we just do deep learning we
don't care about the actual
specific domain
knowledge but my feeling is that
that's still important so uh having
either a computational linguist or
somebody at the a center
is still very very important
are there any inspirations specifically
in nlp drone from theories
i'm not sure if at the moment
we
we are
we are there so there are some things
for example in word embeddings
um
the
the linguistic inspiration comes from
the 50s
the distributional hypothesis and the
idea is that
wars that occur in similar contexts that
tend to have similar meaning
so at the end of the day worduvac is a
yes it's a neural network
but we are counting words that occur
together in a
smart a fancy way but that's what it is
we're counting words that occur together
and the motivation goes back to the 50s
so we have the sort of references things
that come back and forth i'm not uh
specifically
uh familiar with cognitive linguistics
but definitely
the whole
field of linguistics and computational
linguistics
is very very important even though
we often have the tendency of forgetting
that there are other people working in
in the same field so for me i come from
nlp with a computer science background
and my original interest was
building some semantic search engines
and then i realized i don't know
anything about linguistics so every time
i talk to people in the field or i read
the papers
on on the topic i learned something that
is potentially
potentially useful
uh yeah specifically about the the
meaning um
the distribution hypothesis thing it is
not about how
the brain processes meaning but it's
more like like how
language appears
essentially
so short short answer
there's a lot going on but uh specific
examples are
uh you'll need a specialist in
linguistics for a specific example i
guess
all right um
cool i might be to stay for uh for as
long as you want that we have roughly
one hour for this segment here so uh i
guess we're getting
closer to the end i pasted in the chat
earlier my couple of contacts with the
social media newsletter and whatnot so
feel free to to reach out later on
um i'll be
on and off at the during the conference
as well uh
uh if you want to ping me there
uh with with your nfp questions and and
whatnot um conrad are we
we're wrapping up
um
yeah that anybody has any still we still
have uh we still have time for our last
question for last year
if anybody has anything
yeah please please speak up or post in
the chat
um otherwise uh thank you uh marco uh
we're super happy to have had you here
to give us this talk and for you to
share best pi data moment
and then
hope everyone else has a great rest of
the conference
yeah thank you all for for attending and
for engaging and hopefully this this
format will will come back next year as
well
or in any future event
you